then screen junkies studios in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie finds now your host Andy signor
this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
now Netflix has included another reason
why t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network switch today
hello screen junkies welcome to another
live episode of movie fights here every
Thursday 4:00 p.m. and I'm so excited
because we're bringing something back we
did a few months ago that was such a
blast and warm it several fighters who
have come back to fight it's time for
another debut deathmatch here on movie
fights cut to are why do we have 9
amazing new fighters who have never
played this game before some of them
played TV fights but no one here has
played movie fights and you're all gonna
be jockeying for power glory here to
become a regular here on the show the
winner will have to come back and defend
their titles so it gets get excited I
hope you'll want to come back after you
play it but today you're gonna be
fighting some awesome stuff including
what franchise should Pennywise join it
is so popular now that they want to come
on they're gonna put them in something
or they're gonna make an origin movie
it's gonna happen - whether we want or
not what would be the best thing to do
what movie would be in / I'm sorry what
what are what's the worst original movie
that got multiple sequels what's the
worst movie to make 1 billion at the box
office and a lot of their fun stuff so
stay tuned you can follow on online on
Twitter and such or in the comment
section here at hashtag movie fights
live where Dan Morelle will be listening
to your comments chiming in hey Dan this
is me
come on writing exciting I just I always
just had to see new faces here on movie
fights that someone that could maybe
beat Spencer yeah our new champ
yeah champ now because you don't know
it's all right but he'll get there
next to Dan though I'm happy to have fan
and cam Adam tear tell us about yourself
Adam where you from I'm from Phoenix
Arizona and just on vacation a little
bit and really happy that you guys let
me come and watch the debut death man
to here I need your help both you guys
this is this is a tough one cuz they're
gonna come I know guns blazing so help
me make that call let's see who's fight
and let's meet all our competitors first
up she's the social writer here at defy
for smosh smosh games you've done some
stuff for us news wise and stuff
marry risk welcome Mary
[Applause]
in the office and got you in a fight
some nerd cred sounds like it's getting
married in here yeah I'm really excited
to fight I just like I feel I don't get
to scream enough in my daily life some
real rage it's very therapeutic next up
you suck Costa top ten show madness
welcome finally finally got some thank
you so much it I'm glad we have a buffer
if you're gonna be screaming that's
beautiful I got two feet it's not a
problem thank you for having me I've
been here to do movie fights so
hopefully I can continue my winning
streak from over there onto the show
yeah see me fight you mean TV I'm sorry
Paula yeah I know we've had your fellow
a friend Rokon here a lot as well but
someday we'll have to get you to go
toe-to-toe with him it's not a problem I
would destroy genre not a problem
Roka two of us next up he's a director
of DC all-access DC kids it's Brett
register welcome hey what is this
you got to internal ringers right here
yeah you throw me in ya know he doesn't
work for now she doesn't really work for
me but she was near me and well but I
met him so this is everything you guys
have being around Vaughn then after that
we'll have three new fighters let's see
I want to choose everybody just real
quick so make sure we give you all the
super big plug so you know who's
fighting from her show movies with Meg
on YouTube it's Meg McCarthy welcome
back are you feeling throw up but I'm
mixed up I'm so happy to have comedian
dancer and afterbuzz host he was also a
writer an honest trailers way back in
the day I don't know why I'm gonna bring
you back to write some more if you're
willing
I am so full of information in my head I
like to leave so I'm so excited to be
here and I'm too excited
all right all that information sleep
here you push your mic over so they can
share it next I can't reach that far
next up she's hosted a hyper otoko and
partner at twitch TV it's Michelle
chubby bunny I'm sorry I'm talking about
water fights maybe you'll come back for
the run too if you will say you do today
it's so happy to have her she's host of
afterbuzz it's Yale title hey how you
feelin you play TV fights a place do you
know how the format works I am so ready
so ready you should all be scared next
up I think he's the associate producer
over H Mo's know and content manager to
cue it's a scary ride yeah yeah I'm good
I'm nervous but I'm stepping up from TV
fights so hopefully fingers crossed I do
okay no pressure
yeah all right I know a lot of fans are
excited to see here hopefully no it does
have to get past this mad monster the
scariest man in the room mr. Evan I go
what's up Evan I'm going to be here yeah
no Yuri Nicky show way back in the day
you are a horror fan you know your stuff
you've been in this business enough
you're how you feeling to come here and
fight these people no the day another
fight tough over there look he's taking
everyone out of the city bear good good
angle all right well that's our fighters
today it's gonna be a good fight stay
tuned
these three are gonna stay up here the
rest of you guys if you don't mind
you'll sit over in the couch and we'll
get you in round two then round three
and then the winner of this will win if
everyone's listening the viewers will be
voting for this another person to get a
second chance you two will go
head-to-head so there is one rule
everybody you are no longer allowed to
tweet for votes okay because there will
be polls and such we are watching if you
vote and tell your fans mid-show to vote
you will be disqualified that clear
I'm off I don't want a popularity
contest it's not about who has the
bigger social media following it's about
who did the best argument
so no more campaigning the campaigning
stops you but you at home will be
helping determine who makes this so pay
attention at home
let's get you the shall we yes yes
that 10 fights
round one guys there's no real reason
for this question it just was asked and
I thought it was a good question what's
the worst original movie to get multiple
sequels Mary we're going to you first
what's the worst original movie to get
multiple sequels okay no brainer worst
original movie is definitely Twilight
not only is it a movie that should have
never gotten sequels it's a movie that
should have never been made based on a
book that should have never been written
because Stephenie Meyers herself admits
it was based on a fantasy she had of her
own life and potentially a mass per Tory
dream so I really think that those
qualifications don't deserve a franchise
also Kristen Stewart is a dead fish are
you against that but we'll see Matt what
are you picking I chose transformers the
worst in my personal opinion it's the
only of all competitors that put forth
options the only one I had any
expectation of wanting to see when when
it was announced I was like oh my god
CGI's gotten to a point where this could
be an amazing movie and Michael Bay you
know what I enjoyed the rock he can make
an excellent action film and this film
makes no sense from top to bottom there
are so many points in it where you're
like I don't understand what's going on
they violate the characters like it's
very simple it's a simple template for
numerous characters and throughout just
like yeah I don't want to do that we're
gonna do this other thing it doesn't it
makes it I mean it's absolutely
ludicrous
it is beyond it is the worst all right
Brett what are you picking I picked
Resident Evil because it's one of the
all-time best horror games and they made
a mediocre sci-fi movie out of it beyond
that they kept making sequels and they
keep making sequels so we've never
really gotten a true Resident Evil movie
that's it right a good start reasonable
guys fight it out why is your movie the
worst original movie that got multiple
sequels transformers is the worst
because to start simply with the
Transformers themselves Optimus Prime I
don't know where has a mouth the first
time you meet him he's the only
transformer that does it how do you
violate the only thing there's numerous
points at that there's they introduce a
character jazz so you've never heard of
and it is so racist over-the-top like it
wouldn't succeed walks in who's like
would what's up [ __ ] and you're like
excuse me there's a transformer that
cusses and is also racist and at one
point bumblebee pops off a codpiece
which implies he has a penis and pees on
John Tudor Oh what is happening in this
film there's another point where it's
Josh Duhamel erna that fight with the
scorpion transformer and he grabs a cell
phone and calls the Pentagon literally
gets on the phone with an operator was
like I need the Pentagon and they patch
him through
I'm sorry this is the Pentagon just have
an open number we can all call and just
like hey put me in with NORAD yeah yeah
just patch me through I don't need
security clearance or anything try that
this movie does this repeatedly
throughout she's like I don't have the
slightest clue what's going on this
thing is a turd of a movie okay sure but
it has a plot and I don't see that
having a plot at all is in a really like
important part of being a movie that
watches a franchise and the plot of
Twilight is literally like emo girl
moves to emo town meets supernatural emo
dude and they make five flippin movies
about it that is too many movies for not
having any plot also I would like to
point out sure you know he gets peed on
but that isn't some comedy acting Gi
character no no Megan Fox can act about
it with one tip and Kristen Stewart
Cameron her entire body of work please
dead dead soul is soulless sad lady if
you think she's have not reacted to
beautiful beautiful shovel face at any
point through that entire day there's no
way
Shia LaBeouf and her never in any
universe do they end up that's Brian
Austin Green she chooses one of the two
of those over in a Shia LaBeouf
yeah I would still watch that then
Twilight because that's still a better
why different expectations going into
[ __ ] that's why trades war is the worst
all of us all of us when that was
announced we all got excited well hey
I'm just turd comes out and you're like
deer cuz that's a good point so we all
picked movies that are based on
pre-existing properties which is
surprising cuz that's how you launch a
franchise however Twilight I'm not gonna
sit here and argue it's a good movie
because it's not however it's an
accurate representation of the crappy
book that it's based on transformers yes
using accurate
reputation I heard all the wax if you
want to go to different fights great
property because Twilight is a good
movie adaptation of a bad book
transformers is a good movie adaptation
of the experience I had as a kid playing
with my transformers Resident Evil is
not a good representation of what it's
based on okay surely it's really about a
good video game movie show me one show
me why did you any expectations whereas
with comic book like it's easy to get
right it's a haunted house story that
devolves into a really interesting
sci-fi story so if you put all the
sci-fi up front it doesn't work but it's
it's simple yeah they needed to make a
horror movie it's the easiest genre to
get right because the fans give it so
much leeway but Tracy the only video
game should be the easiest you have a
hundred-foot robots fighting how is that
not entertaining it I was bored I think
that both of those films actually have
entertainment value I can guarantee
right now that you would watch
transformers or Resident Evil right now
over sitting through five [ __ ]
Twilight movies no watch the first I
think three resident evil movies and I
had to get out it's also even use the
main characters in the first movie a big
thing with film is that it's a
collaborative medium and so when you're
looking at whether a movie is good or
bad you can't just say do I enjoy this
film you have to say we're the artisans
working on this film doing their best
work and you look at something like
transformers which has incredible CGI
which like soundtrack is pretty okay
like it had some good actors there's
some pretty people in it you look at
Resident a transformers evil I mean
you've got some like really cool girls
doing like some [ __ ] action sequences
I'm so sorry I was talking incredible
artisan work that goes it clean in those
movies with costumes in cinematography
in toilet you have sparkling vampires
playing baseball that is no one's best
work no one can pretend that they're
proud of what they did on Twilight
there's literally
plot there's no story and they made five
of them and there were only four books
they made fiving them because they
corrected that supported their Resident
Evil they made [ __ ] I think they're
up to 45 sorry and none of them have
have been anywhere close to the original
game and that's kind of my biggest
argument is they keep making them which
pushes the actual resin evil movie we
need and we deserve further away
yeah but part of the question is the
worst original it's also the worst
original for transformers because it is
spawned a cottage industry of crap of
crap there has Twilight to follow-ups
that crossed over 1.2 billion dollars
which puts them higher than 15 countries
as far as GDPs in the world - and
they're terrible like every year when
that's announced i imagine somebody at
the Razzies office just opens up a word
document as a keyboard shortcut for
transformers makes it for without having
seen it six months out that's gonna be
on the worst it's continually it's
always in the discussion for worst movie
of the year every time it comes out sure
and transformers has spawned a lot of
really crappy stuff but did it spawned
Fifty Shades of Grey
because Twilight did and that is really
terrible
Twilight like 20 years ago Twilight
would have been cast with Fabio like
Twilight has existed and will exist
there on like forever which doesn't make
it better no the fact that it that's
like saying sexism is fine it's a
problem your sales and make it better
Fifty Shades of Grey which the fans of
Twilight love it actually created a new
franchise so terrible fits within a very
specific audience okay so if you even if
you are a you're saying okay we're going
for teenage girls well let's look at
what we're teaching teenage girls in
Twilight because literally Edwards like
I'm gonna kill you and she's like let's
date and that is not good we should not
be teaching teenage girls but no after
axe murders that case smell they have no
time to lose girl [ __ ] nobody should use
Twilight reference of anything to do in
their life
or at no time zone it's there like if
Twilight is the movie you have for the
teenage women and the people who like
those things if that's the only movie
you have and that's the one you have to
look at that can't be the one that
spawns for more movies because it's so
bad that's based on the book they're
taking it and this is like all right
here's the outline from the book the
movie based on a book it might be one of
the best ones cuz it's missing the weird
piano scene no that's in the book
transformers like nothing nothing makes
sense in a society example that makes
sense so it's somehow just laser etches
the glasses your family if you want to
what we're talking space reviving
vampires how is your argument any more
catalyst sparkling vampires alright
alright I've done about just running it
alright the point I'm having trouble cuz
I'm hearing good things from all three
of you so I need let's get refocused
here and your final thoughts as we go
around why is your movie worse than the
other two and it can be about the movie
itself the franchise had created etc etc
but you've sold me all through your
movies suck I believe you you got to
give me in your closing why is your
movie worse than the other two and we're
gonna come back to you merry final
thoughts go ahead okay the reason
Twilight is the worst number one way too
many women look at it as a real
representation of what life should be
number two it's a masturbatory fantasy
that was made into a five feature
franchise and that's insane number three
it has Anna Kendrick in it and that's
just not fair to Anna Kendrick I really
like Anna Kendrick and what is she doing
as the angry mean girl in Twilight I
don't know stop ruining people's careers
with Twilight also Taylor Swift's
ex-boyfriend isn't it doing that yeah
that gave us and her a high profile
no it gave and Kendrick
I'm just gonna say axe murderers is not
a good relationship model to follow and
let's stop teaching our tweens that all
right Matt final thoughts as to why
transformers is worse than the other two
Transformers is the worst because I like
most of the people or guys in this room
grew up loving 3 cartoons 3 and we've
we've seen over the years that you can
elevate something that was meant for
kids into adults look at the Dark Knight
look at Captain America Civil War you
can take something that is you know it's
predicated upon the the belief that it's
only for kids and make it for kids for
adults for all ages and transformers
just fails on that at every point and it
also fails in itself it sets up rules
for the real world and the fictitious
world with the Transformers they don't
make any sense it just violates itself
left and right it just said it throws
out any kind of rules or order or ideas
and just says I am gonna make more
explosions and guess what that's just
gonna blow people away from having to
follow any kind of plot any kind of
story care about any of these characters
I mean it's it it is disgusting because
the worst part is it is now destroyed
that franchise for a future generation
because they believe that it's just
crappy movies that there isn't a wealth
of source material that we all grew up
on and loved it and no there's amazing
movie in there somewhere
whereas now we just have once again a
cottage industry of crap and Michael Bay
just can continue to know crank out turd
after turd after turd because explosions
sell tickets and that's all that matters
Brad final thoughts well bottom line is
resonance President Evo was one of my
favorite games and it was one of the
most unique experiences I had had at
that point gaming know again we had a
few PC games we had seventh guest and
phantasmagoria that did the horror genre
but none of it that had the impact and
scares that Resident Evil had so then to
give that franchise to Paul WS Anderson
to make a movie that is so heartless and
soulless and devoid of the original
content it's right up there with the
Super Mario Brothers movie it's the only
parallel I can make so what I'm saying
is Resident Evil is as bad as the Super
Mario Brothers movie which would have
been my pick if they had subjected us to
more sequels to that movie
all right there we go Dan coming to you
first thoughts of things to add and
thoughts and then Adam I'll get your
thoughts to quickly some things that
were pointed out with people watching
problem child
there's a guy out David Wilson on
Twitter as a bone to pick with problem
child baby geniuses Alvin and the
Chipmunks many many terrible franchises
i I had I think for for me
Mary advances easily I think she did a
very good job of proving why Twilight
was a terrible movie so we have to pick
one to eliminate in this room that's not
you know you one person gets the point
right it's pick one person that's going
away no one person gets the point one
person gets the point for game they was
choice look at the second point for me
Matt for me Mary would get the point
only because I thought Mary stay very
focused on why the movie Twilight was
bad and I thought that both Matt and
Brett got a little of their argument a
little commingled in with the adaptation
and their love for the original and and
I if it were STEM education
yes but here's Adam chiming that a big
but here's what I was worried because I
thought she got so hung up on it Willem
and look up to it but then they got her
pretty hard like it's a great adaptation
of a bad book so as a worse way where
Matt surprising me with more of like
it's explosions not plot and it's
destroyed it's created a whole cottage
industry he got me a little bit more
Razzie that was to why transformers as a
platform is actually worse or as whether
we liked whether or not like it did what
the fans of the book wanted it to
whereas I don't know so I'm torn but a
fair interesting thought that just Adam
real quick what are your thoughts yeah I
think back at the point on this one
Brett was a little bit caught up on the
source material think about too much in
the love of that game and movie not the
movie but that had a good balance
between source material and it why it's
a bad movie and then the Razzies comment
where you can just now it's you know
it's just gonna be a terrible movie that
kind of sealed the deal for me yeah I'm
gonna go against your dam but if you
agree with me Adam I'm gonna take that
into heart and give Matt the first point
so Matt you may go on to the round but
that's not over you guys now can vote
you disagree you agree with Dan there
and think Mary should have gotten that
point you can go vote for Mary now or
you can vote for Brett if you think he
made the better argument the winner of
the fan vote will come for the last
round to get a second chance to go they
get speed round of the other winner do
so Mary Oh Brett it's not over
yeah that very good job do not go tweet
you're not allowed to go tweet and tell
people it's only people watching I want
to go vote they have your initials up
it's M R and B are I believe I hope that
happened mr for Mary and B are for Brett
- who should give a sec how are they
voting I don't think we've told them
there's a second a poll on Twitter that
they are supposed to put up David I hope
put up cuz he told me was gonna put up
the initials M R versus and then option
to be R and you're voting for who should
get the second chance to come back and
fight again who gave the better argument
based on the arguments thank you guys
all of you can step out and Matt will
see you again and hopefully will marry
Brett when are you gonna come back let's
go to round 2 I need to bring in our
next fighters let's bring in Meg
McCarthy Dave child and Michelle come on
up guys
[Music]
and if that voting doesn't end up Meg
McCarthy you ready to do this I am I am
I think yes all right Dave child's any
questions again no all right question to
round 2 what franchise will be most
improved by adding penny wise you know
after the success of this hit movie we
are not gonna see just one penny wise
movie we will see many I think that's
fair to bet we want you guys to pitch
can be creative can be real can be funny
I will judge funny too creative whatever
you got let's hear what would be the
most which franchise will be most
improved if you've made a movie with
penny wise and we're starting with you
this time Dave Jon
okay listen there is a franchise that is
now 21 years old its old enough to drink
so it should be old enough to appeal to
their older audiences and that is
Pokemon and guess what Pennywise is
basically a Pokemon his name is penny
wise for one he'll be a whole lot bigger
than that
he'll probably more like Mewtwo he's a
powerful psychic pokémon already you can
make the argument that he's already in
that franchise all they need to do is
make a live action horror Pokemon movie
and guess who it should start
it should star penny wise that's what
I'm thinking that's what I'm arguing
here today all right I'm making the
world of Harry Potter
imagine in a world where Voldemort has
been approached as a child by penny wise
as his name and penny wise makes a deal
you know what photo more you're not so
bad you're also hunting down children
I'm gonna come back in a little bit I'm
gonna help you out so when vulnerable
retirement returns to hunt down the
three the trio look at these cute little
babies he's gonna come along with them
and he's gonna take our souls I'm making
my flutes so in my in my perfect world
penny wise would join the Harry Potter
cast and wreak havoc on the magical
worlds of the Harry Potter's alright
well here more that sounds great so far
two very interesting pitches meg what
are you pitching alright it's about to
get real crazy I'm pitching that penny
wise improves Suicide Squad
okay the main reason is to be the
Joker's brother alright to things that
were wrong with Suicide Squad but
characters were OneNote and the plant
was like men you have these amazing
comic-book characters right and you're
bringing them to the big screen and you
don't really get anything new and
different alright but I hate to say it
Jared Leto was right and needed to be
more artistic and the way it makes
things more artistic is to give things
more depth to give characters more
layers and you know how you do that
family drama let's see why these two
guys chose the red lipstick life I want
to know
want to know how they went from men or
boys to clowns let's do this all right
we got Suicide Squad Oh keep on and
harrypotter fight it out guys okay first
thing I want to say is the adding
another killer clown to suicide squad
will not solve Suicide Squad it'll just
be another killer clown also Pennywise
is no one's brother because he is an
ancient monster that has fallen onto the
earth and is buried under dairy and his
Chris's arch-nemesis in the books I
don't know if they're gonna use this in
part two but in the books his arch
nemesis is a giant cosmic turtle what
does that sound like it sounds like a
Pokemon in the water pokemon either
because if you put Pennywise on Pokemon
movie what is it for the franchise
nothing it completely changes it the
question here is what friend does most
improved not cute at all also think
about the franchise franchise as a whole
Pokemon is also a video game system
which also means Pokemon go imagine
playing Pokemon go brute Harry Potter is
killer we don't need to improve it
Pokemon everything you need to improve
Suicide Squad yes okay supernatural
stuff but guess what's in Suicide Squad
supernatural stuff we can fit this in
maybe he was possessed maybe whoa hold
on who was he who was as a child then he
came maybe he got possessed and that's
when he became penny wise the
supernatural who was penny wise before
Pennywise was a child scorpion monster
yeah
films here guys we saw him so I think it
would improve the franchise because
would add more gory action he has
sometimes kids go here and there and
they get big in magic and death and just
kind of burn and die but here we have
kids being torn apart limb by limb by by
a penny wise so I think the I'm and
Harry Potter it adds this whole other
dimension
it makes the stakes even higher it adds
more spooky drama and then it the magic
versus centuries-old beats the whole
being so I think that would be a whole
note arc in the Harry Potter series I
mean you know you have a kid Pokemon has
a primary kid audience so does Harry
Potter Suicide Squad has more don't
watch the movie why because we need
Pennywise in it listen okay
Harry Potter has matured with its
audiences it's gotten darker and darker
and darker and that's what Pokemon can
do and it can get there also the thing
with Harry Potter is that already has
creatures that feed off fear and despair
those are called Dementors it also has
Voldemort who is also a really badass
villain it doesn't need another terrible
villain you guys okay what they need to
do is just improve the killer Klowns
they have not add more killer clowns to
the mix that's not gonna do it they
don't need more characters
everyone loves a killer clown let's do
this pokemons clone is mister my music
on
although he's on a person yeah but he's
a Pokemon and that's what I'm saying
Pennywise is a giant scary mr. penny
wise from human form into like a force
of nature into like a little okay this
is what's gonna happen in the Pokemon
dark movie there's a there's a dark
there's a stuttering trainer who is
lonely he doesn't have any friends so
who does he get he gets all the dorky
pokemon that are around this is all
live-action so you'll see them you'll
get he'll get coughing who has asthma
problems he'll get magic harp is just
Magikarp Snorlax is picked on because
he's a fatty so he gathers all these
Pokemon but there's a dark force taking
over the town taking over the town it
could be dairy or it could be a new
place maybe he moved over and it turns
out they find Pennywise he is a Pokemon
he's always been a Pokemon he's more
powerful than Mewtwo even who they made
a movie about who is a psychic - no I
think Pennywise is is a Pokemon he'll be
a psychic-type it'll be a super powerful
psychic type he'll change his form
according to what he feeds off of he
already is a Pokemon there's a giant
cosmic turning force of nature
I heard enough from you I mean as your
final thoughts are your good Michelle
give me a little bit more why Harry
Potter over these two would be the
franchise more improved so with the
Suicide Squad if you added Evi Pennywise
to Suicide Squad you he would get lost
in the menagerie of already crappy
villains it would just get lost there's
so much character and so much so many
random things having that movie it would
eat lost it wouldn't prove the movie at
all and Pokemon it doesn't fit the whole
universe of the franchise the franchise
itself is bright colorful primary colors
and it's for little kids that's what the
franchise is totally changing it
wouldn't improve it for me it would
improve my franchise because it's adding
to an already great villain cast you
would fit right
in with all the other horrible things
that exist for these kids that are
fighting
he's add extra spooky element and it
would also add a little bit more battle
action to Harry Potter that it's kind of
missing there's only a lot in like the
last movie but you add penny wise you
get lots more gore real quick it would
get real super super fast all right Meg
that's why we don't need more gore in
Harry Potter those films are perfect it
is a great franchise the question was
which franchise would be most improved
you guys we need Suicide Squad to be
more improved that is the root of the
question here alright and there's so
much we can do picture Pennywise joining
Suicide Squad a militarized Pennywise
that be so badass even if it's in the
key art you can see it you can see the
poster also Pennywise lives in new
hampshire near that haunted house
already
he needs to be close to Gotham City he's
not Britt you can have Pennywise with a
British accent I mean we can't do that
does no no that's not fit here I think a
force of nature could just travel with a
British accent I feel like it's a deal
breaker for me you guys would be so fun
to add them to Suicide Squad we're
getting a standalone joker movie this
could be the little tease that we need
it but something to get us like revved
up for that and understand why the Joker
is the way he is because a family drama
what happened it came down to be for the
counter-arguments and being able to
defend themselves and I think Dade
knocked down everything as weird as it
is yeah any counter any punch they had
he counter punch back so yeah when he
said yeah the mentors are redundant that
was a valid point doesn't need more
villains he didn't have a lot of this
points dan what did you think yeah I'm
gonna channel my any inner Andy Jackson
a little bit say this is this is kind of
rough for me dog but for me dog
I was feeling the same thing I nobody
landed a real knockout blow for me but
it came down to the fact that Dave's
seemed to have considered every thought
given the given to the fight in total I
have to give the edge to that it just
seemed like the most well thought out of
the choices so yeah it was a close
second so Dave I'm moving you on next
round come to kill but Michele Meg both
really good arguments and now you at
home will be able to determine who moves
on to the next round
mm for Meg or MN for Michele and Harry
Potter
you can go vote now don't know tweeting
but you at home if you watch the fight
and you thought who gave the better
argument mm for Meg mm for Michelle on
the Twitter poll that'll go up right now
thank you guys Dave we'll see you in a
minute and we'll see one of you back
Bravo let's bring up our next fighters
wow this has been a good show you guys I
love it thank you for bringing it yell
come on up Evan and ace but I'm pom-pom
well you're the next fighters on movie
fights here we go we have a Twitter
question coming in Evan you're the
middle ace you're in the end this is
comes in from I hated Chad so hard on
Twitter yell tiger welcome how you
feeling
don't you want you got you guys got a
little bit of answers you got to watch
some yeah you see how heated it's got no
pressure now shrinking pressure yeah
there's a switch you shouldn't should
push you up if you stand up well I might
just stand yeah you can stand hi Evan
mad monster you're are you ready to
bring it
yeah I gotta move this chair then you
can lift this up too it goes up there if
you wanna look at the floor yes ace yeah
you ready I'm good oh yeah no pressure
cuz like this that was too strong round
I think that adds pressure hey I think
it adds a lot of pressure
alright here we go best this comes into
my head Chad sword best surprise this
isn't an honor of best surprise cameo in
any movie not on poster or opening
credits that's how we just it has to be
a surprise cameo best surprise cameo
movie this is the rumor that Joseph
gordon-levitt is apparently in the last
night it's not the last night the last
Jedi transform my brain still I don't
know why the last Jedi a dress of weird
lemons apparently in that as a surprise
cameo not a surprise now cuz everyone
ruins everything but we want to ask who
is the best surprise cameo in any movie
it's up to you now he's removing it in
there first who is the best surprise
cameo I picked Bill Murray in Zombieland
I feel like this one not only combines
the two comedic elements I feel like the
best part of it is that he's playing
Bill Murray which is something that I'll
get into eventually but yes I feel like
overall this is just completely
hilarious cameo alright yeah so what
makes a good cameo is something that is
unexpected it's quick and it doesn't
detract from the story that's why I
picked a Bob Saget in half-baked I'll
argue more later
oh she's playing that card Abin who are
you picking hands down giant up in Peter
DeLuise in 21 Jump Street Oh
alright Johnny Depp and Peter del Louise
alright fight it out guys so here's the
thing about your choices guys so Bill
Murray his storyline as funny as it was
detracts from the story all of a sudden
were dealing with Bill Murray and then
we got a deal with his death spoiler and
the problem with that is that it takes
away from the story where's Bob Saget
appears says an iconic line which I have
chosen not to say because children watch
ha ha ha but he comes on he does this
thing yeah and then you get to remember
this beautiful thing that happened it
doesn't take you out of the story he
gets shouted the
line all the time in his personal life
now it's so memorable we all know it now
we're saying in our heads I don't have
to say it out loud
but that's the problem with both of your
choices Johnny Depp and Peter DeLuise we
knew they were coming back to 21 Jump
Street they are 21 Jump Street that
wasn't surprising we knew it was gonna
happen that's why I feel like you make
an interesting point I feel like cameos
mistake a miios personally and I feel
like for everyone watching is the
comedic out especially because all three
of our movies are funny movies I think
the best thing a cameo can bring is
comedy and who better to do that than
Bill Murray Murray is considered one of
the most funny man's in Hollywood of all
time also the fact that he's played Bill
Murray whereas your two versions are
playing a character which is funny it's
cute it's short it's ten seconds long
but mine is playing an actual Hollywood
icon who makes fun of himself who brings
callbacks to his old movies like
Caddyshack with the club hitting him in
the back and actually playing
Ghostbusters and every enacting a
Ghostbusters scene with Emma Stone and
Woody Harrelson it's the combination of
Woody Harrelson's reaction his death
scene which is hysterical which is so
funny because he's showing up there to
actually prank a guy and then get shot
that to me is just funny and the fact
that he's like one of six survivors in
the entire planet he survived a zombie
apocalypse by acting that to me is just
comedy all in a nutshell and it just
adds to the comedic value of an already
funny movie with an already funny cast
it would be great if he was part of the
story and that's what it was but it was
it was part of the story that's the
cameo a cameo is supposed to be quick
it's supposed to be funny it's supposed
to be memorable it's inside your head
and not distract you from the movie but
it's a no no no no second no but my
thing with Bob Saget it might it may
fall into the trap of too quick he says
one line and disappears whereas there's
a good to mine this is silly all right
with all due respect I don't think
you've made a point for me to make a
counter point so I kind of feel between
us
so I know I said I all due respect
Zombieland it's a good pick in fact it
was my second pick okay and you know
Bill Murray was also the writer second
pick they wanted Patrick Swayze Patrick
Swayze got sick so we got bill Marty you
know it was cute because you got to see
this lever you play himself that could
have been anyone if that was Eddie
Murphy whoever it's just interchangeable
you plug it in what's brilliant about
the Johnny Depp cameo and yes I say
brilliant you said you saw it coming
here's the thing yeah everyone was
wondering what is this is this a reboot
is this continuing continuity Johnny
Depp insisted that they bring back Peter
DeLuise he insisted that they both come
back in order for him to do this you got
Hanson you got Doug Penhall that's just
awesome
besides that first act they give it to
you you talk about enhancing story or
whatever there's the story we sat there
and they they Andy Kaufman us you know
boom when they reveal that these are the
original characters we watch these
iconic characters spoiler get killed so
you know you're satisfying the original
fans and you get them killed off by the
incompetence of our current fans benefit
of the Bob Saget cameo is that you
didn't see it coming it was funny
and it didn't detract in the story where
is everyone I'll give you two of the
three
well you here's the thing this is the
time again it's a throwaway cameo he's
supposed to appear be funny and then
disappear and not ruin my feel like I
feel like Bill Murray actually gave
something that made a funny movie
funnier it made it made it even again
but what did he bring to the table is
any where he or anyone else couldn't do
B I mean again I said the Caddyshack
Ghostbusters scene but here's the thing
you're taking you're taking a reboot
which you know there's this trend of
taken like semi pseudo serious
properties and turning them into goofy
comedies so you had Penhall and Hanson
return true to their characters in this
wacky zany
comedy and I just feel like you know it
melded - Jean Ruzicka made it funnier
but my thing about the 21 Jump Street
one and I feel like I'm gonna give my
age with this but to be completely
honest I don't think I'm the only one
who said Oh Johnny Depp's in this movie
cool why is he in this but that's what I
make in 21 Jump Street before my time
[Applause]
hold on as the old man at the table I'll
just lay straight up
Johnny Depp okay for us horror fans
everyone's like Johnny Depp night manam
Street that's pretty badass
you know he made his bones on 21 Jump
Street exactly you didn't know he was
reprising his role you didn't know that
you'd already seen him in the act cuz
and the other thing is you have this
international superstar going back to
his roots and bringing a friend it's now
it felt like the Johnny Depp and Peter
DeLuise appearance in 21 Jump Street
felt a lot like David has often Baywatch
you saw that it was gonna come you knew
is gonna be reference to the old stuff
you knew is gonna be boring and he was
gonna just be there before like Bob
Saget playing against type from the
Family Matters
here's my thing it's really my age the
Bob Saget wants real quick the Johnny
Depp one is like oh it's Johnny Depp a
story like the Bill Murray one made a
funny movie funnier it made callbacks to
his original films and make callbacks to
ghostbusters Woody Harrelson's legendary
minds I'm just saying I'm a zombie when
writers he would have been my second
choice to Patrick Swayze was pretty
inspired to bet it wasn't the story that
they were originally gonna go with it
was gonna be a lot more action sooner
than I think that I want to do that's
exactly but yeah exactly we're arguing
based on the film not what could have
been so I feel like that's what the film
did with Bill Murray mainly wasting our
time during a movie we were made funnier
for an actual legendary well-known cameo
that a lot of people regard it's the
best cameo ruler after everybody Oh
groundbreaking but make it is funnier
dogs real pictus comedies now what
it's a guy that was a comedy legend who
at the time started having a reputation
for being this bitter guy at the Oscars
you know and I feel like his PR guy said
hey while we show people you'd still be
funny Oh guess what good news large
Swayze got sick so we're gonna wrong
made him funnier and it made it fit into
the story he's one of the last people in
the zombie apocalypse left because he's
acting like a zombie that's hysterical
is that this is America yes it is and
the fact that he's dressing up as a
Ghostbuster and actually re-enacting a
legendary movie that I feel like
everyone up here can agree is a
legendary movie Gaucher's and reenacting
we all agree everyone knows who Bill
Murray is and I feel like that gave this
funny edge to the movie that the other
two don't give Bob Saget was too quick
and Johnny you guys have an advantage
exactly you guys have these tagged on
the non sequiturs that were
interchangeable you could took any one
basically 21 Jump Street came at you and
they said yeah everyone's expecting our
obligatory cameos so what they did is
they mix it up they pretty much slipped
it in and let you know hey you guys
already saw these guys they were
undercover boom it was a surprise it's
like they slipped in yes you know it's
coming but that's how that's that that's
part of the reveal it's Hitchcock T and
it doesn't always have to be a
jump-scare or a surprise
sometimes it's what's right in front of
you that you don't see coming which is
exactly what they did with Bob Saget and
half-baked you had this guy sitting in a
rehab center he stands up says the best
line but I feel like that's like you can
turn you free was that Bob Saget well
III can't those amazing this work where
it's like just shrug it off that's
I'll tell you why because I feel like
you know they're not a lot of you know
amazing cameos to choose from in that
probably was scraping the bat barrel I
just feel like anyone could have done
that I feel like I I personally feel
like it's so quick you can turn your
friend to be like was that Bob Saget I
was funny but for the Bill Murray one it
actually gave something different here's
the thing that I feel like is different
between the three of us like I mentioned
before the old Murray is plain Bill
Murray that to me every time an actor
plays an actor it's tough it's something
to balance where you're like are they
gonna really push themselves aren't they
gonna make that was the second best at
the table it's it's funny because he's
making fun of himself and he's played a
caricature of Bill Murray's something
that you feel like what would Bill
Murray be like in the zombie apocalypse
that's what it would be like he would be
acting like a zombie being an idiot
leaning in this giant mansion and bein
Bill Murray which is hysterically I'm
using as your final thoughts as I fare
you got are you okay Mary yeah sorry I'm
coming back to you what was the reason
yours is better than the other two
surprises here's the reason when it
comes to cameos like I said the things
you want is something that's unexpected
why would Bob Saget being half-baked
it's quick because he stands up he says
his hilarious lines there are
interactions from the audience
someone who shots a scene it that's one
of the best lines also and then it
doesn't disrupt the story the problem
with both of yours is that they disrupt
the story what you want when you have a
cameo right it's not a new character
it's not somebody who's part of the
story it's someone who shows up makes
you laugh it sticks in the back your
head forever you will always remember
this a hilarious moment when the dad the
children watch this a self bleep by
yourself bleep drug I used to suck bleep
for bleep I feel like
this man is funnier than that saying I'm
just saying and the Bob Saget saying for
the scene that is so outstanding that he
gets shouted about him sucking bleep for
pain on the street when he's with his
daughters this is something that haunts
him to this day
and he's very proud it's it's the father
from full house who used to suck blade
for bleep guys all right so what makes
it a good cameo yeah I don't final
thoughts yeah I totally got the joke the
thing with you know the film is partial
Native American so now I'm offended so
so here's the thing you know you keep
talking about serving the story and then
a cameo
yeah with with a crappy film that has to
tack on you know a cameo just to you
know be a talking point yes I I guess
you can have a cameo that serves no
purpose I don't feel that Johnny Depp
and Peter DeLuise at all detracted just
because they were able to integrate it
and the reveal I mean it's pretty much
as long as the the Bob Saget scene it's
not like we were sitting with him like
you know Bill Murray we weren't
following the characters being like all
right how long we have to sit through
this it was it was a reveal it was a
punch and I just feel like it had a
handicap it came at you you're expecting
you know where are these guys gonna pop
up and and you didn't see it coming the
first act extra points it's just a game
guys people don't know the no line
didn't know we were talking about it's
of great line
you know that it's true those are three
I think you all have picked three greats
Danny let's go I feel like there were
several movie fights happening in there
and some actual fight yeah I feel like I
I thought a spread up a good point and I
know and I feel like they kind of
shrugged it I was like ah whatever your
being but I thought a sprout up a good
point about not everyone necessarily
knowing connecting to the thing in 21
Jump Street that kind of hit my head a
little bit like that does kind of and
that is a very sinner alliteration 'le
specific and he was speaking from his
own experience so that was kind of a
ting against that that got me and then I
don't know they both I thought that you
know kind of got mixed up in like what
is a cameo what's not a cameo this is a
cameo because it was short but I didn't
get much beyond this was a cameo cuz he
said a funny line and it was really
short and the movie moved on and I
thought the ACE presented the best
argument about the effect on the movie
the performance so I I would have to go
with him thoughts yeah same thing as Dan
it's it just overall it was a more well
crafted argument in my opinion yeah well
so I don't disagree I think I think yeah
you made some great points you know
about the Bob Saget line stuff yeah and
you know your your point about that
isn't disruptive stories where I'm
arguing is that actually true it's a
valid point though in your argument but
that's where I was a little hung up is
that does that actually true because I
do think well I've been you know maybe
got a little intense there he's a very
nice guy and I mean anything mainly and
you should talk afterwards he didn't
mean it I'm sure please yeah I'm sure
that was just he didn't mean to do York
I'm sorry you know I don't think you
didn't mean to be rude I imagine you
know B's anyway said but my point is it
while you are
I wish I was joking now you said the
fact that it is the fact that was so
written in and so smartly put into the
film and that he asked for him to come
back I thought you were at a
disadvantage but then you'd made some
very strong points to me like that was a
really clever thing that he's such a big
man why'd he come back
they were so clever about it I didn't
think all that so that was very good
that said I gotta agree with the couch I
just think Bill Murray
just because Baxter says he would have
been a good choice too doesn't mean that
what Bill Murray did wasn't I got a
great yeah it's sort of a very surprise
moment yeah so I got to give a Stu
points but between these two it's up to
you online that's hit make the vote who
made the better argument is really what
it's come about I was it i bleep bleep
for bleep suck bleep for bleep yeah
from half-baked and Bob Saget vote for
whitey if you want to vote for that as a
surprise cameo based argument or vote
for em4 evan for the giant depp 21
Jumpstreet surprise cameo with peter
dilute Eloise yes I'm a disadvantage
because people that watch 21 Jump Street
aren't on Twitter served the purpose I'm
alright
no thank you all wonderful around you
guys will vote on round who comes back
and now I will bring back the first
three winners do I'm on up say yeah you
stay okay thank you for playing hard
here we go we're bringing back sorry we
have Matt one yeah Dave Matt Dave ace
intense now the next round after this
will be determined by your votes if you
didn't go vote for the players go on
Twitter right now and you can vote for
them all those three rounds the three
winners of those votes will come back
they'll have a round and then you guys
will take them on in the speed round got
it everything makes sense make sense oh
yeah great now this is Round four
hopefully max report prepared you for
good okay from guests in the name on
Twitter what was the worst movie to make
1 billion dollars at the box office
Matt here at first there's a surprising
number of choices there were and what
was interesting is all of you picked
different movies yeah
there's I was I was debating between
four different movies going I I hate all
of these kind of in public and it's
amazing but the one that I hate the most
was the last transformers to beat a dead
horse guys I'm going back to
transformers one more time but age of
extinction
age of extinction I sat through that
thing look they took hundred-foot robots
and put them on hundred-foot robotic
dinosaurs and I was so bored I wanted
the movie to end right then and there
like there's a point at which in the
middle of the action they destroy a bud
light truck and Mark Wahlberg
shamelessly just grabs it it's like at
the end of it is like boom oh god I just
need a tasty drink right now this is a
prod oh it's the label not perfect let
me just readjust that label your guys
you're already guaranteed to make a
billion dollars we really do put product
placement in the middle of this crap
fest of a movie and it's just it's
interminable it just keeps going and
going and going
after two hours I was done after two
hours and twenty minutes I was done I
think the thing is like 228 or some you
know ridiculous like that it's just it's
just an abomination of a film it is the
worst film I've seen in a movie theater
of probably the last what is it five
years or so it is absolutely god-awful
terrible Dave guys it just it just
doesn't get worse than Phantom Menace it
just it just doesn't it's like you guys
went into transformers knowing what
you're getting you knew what you were
getting you just had a great argument
for going in to get know what you're
getting you go into Phantom Menace
hoping to relive the childhood hoping
for that hope and you get half of a
movie talking about trade negotiations
faces characters mennick lorian's and
the most unconvincing love story you've
ever sated your life it just charged our
banks in charge our pinks it just
doesn't get worse that's it all right
hey all right Matt I'm with you brother
I hate transformers but you know what's
worse than age of extension dark of the
Moon Transformers Dark of the Moon is
the perfect
it's literally like the perfect
amalgamation of what makes a shitty
Transformers movie it's horrible human
characters horrible nonsensical action
all combined into one with actually more
human characters than the nonsensical
action which is what people pay to see I
feel like out of the Transformers movies
because they're both [ __ ] so I had to
pick between which one was shittier I
picked Dark of the Moon
because I feel like that one is the
slightly shittier movie that has a love
triangle in a transformers movie with
Patrick Dempsey and Shia LaBeouf and the
model girl which just spells out Michael
you imagine Michael Bay trying to do a
love triangle that in itself is just the
shittiest thing you can possibly imagine
and that's what we got in Dark of the
Moon
so that's my choice sorry I'm not to
show my Carter but I'm gonna need a
little bit of education on which
transformers was which boost last
without making fire and you're again
with the Dinobots and Mark Wahlberg okay
yeah yes but still I'm a little fuzzy so
make sure and you're arguing I'll help
me remember why that transform okay well
I remember all of yours Dave so you're
okay yeah okay
you know here comes here comes the Star
Wars fan in me it comes here it comes
the Phantom Menace man again here is the
generational thing right because I was
born in 1991 I was 8 years old when I
saw the Phantom Menace
it gave us one of the best things out of
any Star Wars movie that is still
regarded and you can act you can ask any
original person the best lightsaber
fight scene we have ever seen in any
Star Wars movie based on choreography
based on action based on Darth Maul or
which one's better to meet you make dark
a night can I just say mole in itself
sells Phantom Menace then they kill
Doraemon and then they look ahead still
it's doing at this badass probably the
Phantom it is versus two transformers is
there are parts of fan of Menace and
characters that I love yes I love in the
movie as a whole is Tara Tara same time
I like much worse my god Jin
Darth Maul the lightsabers into the
blast door and when you go through the
happening
doesn't matter it still has redeeming
parts where is like ancient extinction
there in the beginning
her boyfriend Mark Wahlberg's daughter
is a stunt car driver something in East
Texas that makes a hell of a lot of
sense and they go through like there's
one point there they go into a parking
garage and he just decides I'm gonna
drive out of the third floor and then
there's a ramp below so did he know who
is this like hardcore for cars and I
didn't nobody that's what those movies
are though that's what those movies oh
here's that I'm already a step no I
because what makes that movie good is
are there giant robots do they blow up
things yes
it's dull you have hundred-foot robots
fighting and there is hairless my
pleasure to kill - or box doesn't matter
where's all made the minutes I enjoy
there are parts of it that I was to
watch to this desk when they say women
to go to City rink it's still the holy
lines like the heartbreak over Capulets
everybody does that work
we're not arguing what's the best movie
that we had the best expectations for
were arguing based on quality yes and if
you're gonna argue worst movie to make 1
billion if we're arguing the worst we're
not saying perfect we're not saying
going into it we had expectations no way
I was still born attain to that that I
was a true station station DC's is so
dull it's so but there's five different
buildings what's going on as tall as
that is dude at least you got Dinobots
at least you got you didn't care I mean
ours didn't have Dinobots here's the
dark of the Moon have a love triangle
with Patrick Dempsey and it focused on
Shia LaBeouf trying to find a job for an
hour in the movie an hour and it also
focused on a love triangle when you go
into the movie you want to see action
you got more action in age of extinction
you got Dinobots you've got Optimus
Prime I mean on top year olds love that
Jonathan moon is an improvement to the
previous film it actually is when you're
going into it it has more it has this
weird like Loudoun story it has this it
has this they took out the racist
characters mine that play took out
choices characters very much of an
abundant [ __ ] it's this one you go into
it expecting as bad as the one I got and
it was like hey this one's a little
better it did better it's sold better
really because they gave us more human
stories which we don't want which one's
worse Dave transformers I'm curious I
would say Dinobots I would say that it's
still cool because when you saw are
they're awesome the first time you saw
those things you were like that's a
really cool droid way time time is a
time is always something that Star Wars
fans look at and looking back at the
Phantom Menace you look at
disappointment but you don't look at the
worst Star Wars movie you look at a Star
Wars movie that could have been better
but it still gave a star's mall it still
gave us the best but they don't even
she did they gave him a 25-minute
choreograph best by not signing like
trained-to-go she is make a whole movie
about him and that Jar Jar whole movie
with trying to get a job
Shia LaBeouf trying to get a job at a
Shia LaBeouf is way better than Jar Jar
Binks he'll always be the primary
character where Shia LaBeouf is this
intolerant Lucas that Jar Jar Binks is
what these movies are all about Jar Jar
was geared towards him and his age when
it came out and they loved him they
loved him on Star Wars a new he's just
after the imagination of another hundred
million kids how cool bunny night for me
an age of extinction you watch any of
the Transformers movies and you could
put her on mute and just enjoy the
visuals of it the way it's so flat
they're all eastland green screen it's
just blank they don't know what they're
doing with transformers it's like the
action that's going on dinosaurs every
time Matt why is the age of extinction
worse than Dark of the Moon
it's one of those things of I got conned
into going my friend was like you have
to go I've gone to enough movies with
you that I didn't want to see you're
coming to this good with me and I didn't
think the movies can actually get worse
I was at a point where just like the bar
was set low enough for me and like you
can't you can't do any worse and you sit
through this and there's like four
different villain storylines that all
don't really pay off there's numerous
product placement there's later one with
Stanley Tucci with like a tea or a drink
or something in China there's muddled
character motivations throughout the
entire thing and I walked out going I
don't understand the point of this other
than to make things explode and steal
people's money and that's all it was to
me it was just a cash grab and we can
sell this internationally and we don't
give you know two shits
about your feelings enjoyment of going
to a movie we just want your money and
it was dis ol dark moon didn't do that
too age of extinction was the straw that
broke the camel's back
transformers for me just got
precipitously worse with every iteration
and that was the one where just like
dear God you're not even trying
you just know that we'll make a billion
dollars no matter what so let's let's
hire more CGI animators and let's just
get our free money alright and then you
just said right there cgi animators
that's why people go see this movie this
what dark of the moon did is not do that
and it gave us a Shia LaBeouf love
triangle with a model and Patrick
Dempsey and it gave us a love triangle
that's an hour into the movie and it's
also him trying to find a job when
people go into the Transformers movies
they don't want to see Michael Bay
trying to sell you on a love story they
want to sell you on action and what the
as shitty as that is and I agree with
everything you just said but the problem
is it gave us Grimlock and as much as
everyone who who was like ready to hate
they were like at least Grimlock to
enjoy it
no but the thing is exactly the great
job scenes are great but we're not yeah
it's a kiss or eating the other freakin
robot it's for action it's great for CGI
you know but what it is it's a love
story and try and fit in an actual
character piece in a Michael Bay
transformers movie it doesn't work and
that's why I feel like it's worse than
age of extinction
also with Phantom Menace it's just it's
so clearly not the worst billion dollar
movie and it's also as someone who saw
it and it's a different generation
because I feel like this is a
generational thing as an eight-year-old
Darth Maul is so freaking cool and and
again like you said quiet on Gen Obi one
these are really cool things in the
movie that it's not even on the same
level as transformers and I feel like
dark of the Moon look at the love story
okay final thoughts here okay if you
just look at the love stories itself
you're just seeing okay Shia LaBeouf is
making out with a model but that's great
because they're both pretty I don't care
and this they try to be are you a
princess 18 year old meeting up with a
10 year old and this is the love story
that's supposed to ignite the entire
Star Wars world it just falls so flat
instead they try to put like they tried
to put something like the droid fights
it's just it's so it was so
disappointing and the heartbreak itself
just makes it far worse also it's not
shot well it's it's flat
they don't use practical effects as much
as they could've and it ends up being
like not even visually interesting it
has one good star wars at one good
lightsaber fight but that one lightsaber
fight is as good as all of those legs
Transformers movies put together because
Jan about action and visual it's just
about that so it's like those are action
visual movies that aren't about story
because it tries to have story it tries
to have you when you're growing up on
transformers you just want to be friends
with a transformer and when you see
transformers you feel like that's still
possible when you're growing up with
Star Wars you want to become a Jedi and
then you find out you can't because you
without Phantom Menace we wouldn't have
what we have now with Rey that's just
fact oh it would what George Lucas
brought in through those movies we have
those things we have the Clone Wars
series which is regarded as one of the
best animated series now that is based
off the Phantom Menace we have the rebel
series which is a great animated series
that is based off the Phantom maker has
just done Revenge of the Sith and have
all those things that's happened what
about fine because we still have Darth
Maul and he was still in and he gave us
some fantastic moments and in the rebel
series when he fought up against obi-wan
we wouldn't have known
one I feel like The Phantom Menace
brought a lot that a lot of people
overlook don't have the moon gave us too
much human characters and great action
Matt final quick coaches I'd let them
talk more just being fair I appreciate
that thank you very much
nice to have you Judah cater on your
side
listen think of it like this according
to Dante there are seven circles of hell
the Phantom Menace doesn't even sniff
the circles hey you know age of
extinction is that inner very concentric
Satan's butthole of Dante's Inferno it
is the worst of the worst you're in
there with all the souls that can never
be saved there beyond purgatory they are
in the depths of hell and guess what on
repeat all they're playing is the age of
extinction over and over and over just
to drive those mad people even further
mad because this one was rough for me
because I'll show my cards now cuz I'm
offensive Matt really screwed up for me
because he didn't mention going to China
he didn't mention that Juliet and Romeo
Claus which was the way worst love story
this when they pulled up the card and
justify that she's a minor so many
things I didn't hear aside from just a
lot of explaining that it's bad but not
enough Tommy why it's bad even though I
personally thought that was the mat and
then Phantom Menace they did knock them
down by saying there are some good
moments and then taste points out will
that Grimlock and mine has a love
triangle to Patrick Dempsey I didn't get
more than that either so I need what did
you guys hear that helped make you make
a call it again it's all pretty close I
think I I would I would side with ace
though because nobody nobody really said
what was really bad
yeah about it really like and ace the
one thing that you didn't pull out I you
should have done the giant worm in the
tower scene that I actually that was the
best part of the movie for me yeah but
it's I don't know I
very close edge but I have to go with
ace on this one Dan yeah go with ace on
this one I this is not my first movie
fights rodeo and I've heard many people
argue these movies in separate rounds
I myself have argued all of them and
I heard that Dave's argument I hate the
movie but and it's got this and I know
and I heard Matt I have railed against
age of extinction so many times and and
the product placement and the robe up
you could say that about Dark of the
Moon
- so I was like you know and then but
but I thought that ace actually was like
he came at it's like it's not even that
it's product placement and it's not even
that it's robots it's the story it's the
character it's this and and right when
she even labeled down with kudos you
remembered the story which I didn't get
from Matt in this movie this movie fails
so much just like I had the time room
for the movie fights viewer I have to go
with the argument that hits me the best
and I felt like the greatest hits on the
other two and I thought I heard
something a little bit different from a
little close because he did give us
reasons but and they were funny so you
were close but those two movies are
worse they did they said it they're true
and I got it because I didn't hear
enough from why age isn't better worse
he's got the point based you're moving
on the final round
[Applause]
you guys are both invited back I'm very
impressed with you guys that was a
wonderful showing I may come back to ask
you guys to chime in at the end so stay
tuned but ace all you guys go back let's
see who won our fan photo so for the
next three polls doing a Gotham yeah you
have them all I do I'm on the winner fan
vote is round one the winner for the fan
vote is Mary another place another
chance to win this showdown you guys can
cross there yep
all right and then round two who won
that one round two is very close but the
winner for round two is Meg
[Applause]
Hey round three is it is a razor-thin
margin I just got to go where it's going
right now right now it is 5149 for Yale
so yell comes back for razor-thin margin
that one was going back and forth it may
still but you gotta call it at some
point so you don't respect for round
three not expecting that
yeah we're really clip mine shows the
other but hey 149 we can sit here wait
wouldn't do a speed round considered
wait for it no I guess yeah you called
it let's finish what it is but man that
was close you guys yeah it's I'm still
seeing 5149 so man hey you got your here
he did it that's the timing Network yeah
to everyone else we'll bring you back to
thank you all Bravo here we go this is
now round two the winner of this round
will take on a sincere
to see who wins this one comes in from
Luke lush well sorry Luke I didn't say
your name right what two actors have the
worst on-screen chemistry all right you
guys know your answers hopefully you
know good because I knew you weren't you
didn't know you're coming here we go man
meg you are first tell us I'm sorry
you're in the short chair I am in the
which two characters have the worst
on-screen chemistry
all right well Andy I picked Pierce
Brosnan and Denise Richard in the world
is not enough and I'll tell you why the
only chemistry in this movie is between
Denise Richards boobs and that tank top
all right because there is nothing going
on between her and bond in this one all
right she plays a nuclear physicist all
right I'm all about female empowerment
I'm like so excited I'm with my girls
not here well but um I don't believe
this woman's got brains like she's got
great boobs no I'm not like necessarily
a boob girl all right
as you can tell but I was so distracted
by her boobs in this like I couldn't
even like think about anything else and
I feel like I feel like Pierce felt the
same way I'm not gonna lie all right she
couldn't even act smart um usually at
the end of every Bond movie all right
there's always that that scene where
he's making love with his Bond girl and
you're like maybe this is the girl maybe
they're gonna get like right off to the
sunset and get married okay you know
what you know it's not right you know
it's gonna not gonna happen but you're
like maybe I don't know but after this I
was like no just like hit it and quit it
bond just hit it and quit it like I did
not want this to happen because there's
no chemistry it's like the first time
we're at bond who makes all the ladies
swoon just there was like nothing there
there's nothing all right all right yeah
I picked Dakota Johnson and Jamie Dorian
from Fifty Shades of Grey
the thing about Fifty Shades of Grey
is that Christian Grey is supposed to be
this
see powerful man that makes you want to
give yourself over to a man and
Anastasia is supposed to be this week
doesn't realize she's pretty girl who
wants to explore her sexuality and what
we got were two stick figures who are
afraid to touch each other
and you know he's got all these toys to
play with but he's like afraid to touch
them and he's afraid to have them touch
her and she's afraid to get excited and
it really didn't work for me because
when I go to see Fifty Shades of Grey
I want to be in a room full of women
that are going yeah we're basically
about to watch porn together and that's
not what you get you've got a cucumber
didn't you I definitely did not Wow Mary
what are you picking obviously in
picking Natalie Portman and Hayden
Christensen in attack of the clones and
Revenge of the Sith
which one uh uh we're good to the set
okay um because honestly that's a love
that was supposed to like sparked an
entire franchise that we already loved
and instead it almost killed a franchise
and that's not okay you guys it's really
important love and I feel like more
righted Road on that relationship than
most other relationships probably any
other relationships ever in a Star Wars
movie and that was the one you decided
to be the worst with also how do you not
have chemistry with Natalie Portman she
is beautiful and awesome spread it out
all right I have a couple of stuff to
say first of all um Jamie's wife I
believe in real life was very upset at
the chemistry going on there that she
didn't want him to even do the second
film feel like that was a thing that
happened and so then maybe there was
some chemistry which she felt it you
know if boy's wife felt it then like we
must have been feeling I do not see that
interview where they're like super
uncomfortable and you want to die well
because they're doing something under
the table me talk about uncomfortable
because this is part of my issue with
the the romance of Fifty Shades of Grey
okay we're talking about two characters
who have on-stream chemistry together
that like love each other those aren't
characters that are ever supposed to
love each other they're supposed to just
like have a lot of sexual intercourse
time
to take us right up stand up but your
we're missing is that this first film is
supposed to be them getting to know each
other and feeling the chemistry and
growing into love in a relationship so
it's supposed to be there and it's
supposed to be such an attraction that
they can't keep away from each other but
it supposed to be a sexual attraction
yes so I think what you're missing there
is the D like sexual like this rule I
want to like rip your clothes off and
like you know do some do some things on
that I'll talk when I'm Sara because hi
children um but I think the problem with
Star Wars though is that you have an
entire franchise that's resting on the
definer workings of a relationship
you're not just talking about sexual
attraction it's easy for two hot people
to be attracted to each other it should
be easier than it is but I believe those
two hot people were more attracted to
each other then I believe that a Jedi
was breaking all of his vows and
everything he'd ever worked for fir girl
that he kind of was like fun because in
that chemistry we get one of like a
really famous quote from Star Wars I'm
probably gonna misquote it but you're
breakin my heart
I mean but what I found is an amazing
actress that I will always believe any
question about that
were you personally so distracted by
Denise Richards boobs that you didn't
notice there was chemistry or not
happening I think I was jealous I'm
saying that's just manhood it it's you
know that's not chemistry that's you
know getting distracted but the point is
is that Fifty Shades of Grey
all right a lot of people and whether we
like it or not think there's chemistry
there same thing with Haydn and Natalie
but no one remembers the world is not
enough for the chemistry no one cares
people were so disappointed in Denise's
a Bond girl because there was no
chemistry this was just like such an
upset well actually that's a really
great point that no one cares
straight up no one cares about the
chemistry of bond and some Bond girl
because there are so many Bond movies
but this was exactly exactly
Darth Vader and the one and only Darth
Vader couldn't convince me that he was
in love with a beautiful amazing there's
so many girls I'm sorry the one and only
Darth Vader story that's been officially
made canon and a film that's been
released that's not animated but he
brought up a good point because there's
been so many Bond girls Vaughn has
always been able to have chemistry with
all those women
ra even the ones that were the
characters one has developed or no
matter what but like this one there was
a zero chemistry that's got a stand for
something good see here's the thing is
that you have a future in this
relationship regardless of what happened
in that movie we know there is a future
in that relationship and bond sleeps
around and gets new women all the time
whereas this was the first of a trilogy
IV Bond films we watched them for the
Bond girls when you watch them for that
relationship finish as I was saying
sorry the first is the first of a
trilogy and if it didn't work there was
a chance that it was going to ruin
everything they wanted to recast him
there was so much riding on this
relationship that it mattered and they
had to go together and and learn to have
chemistry whereas they were gonna end up
together regardless right but but the
whole the whole driving force of even
making those stupid prequels in the
first place and it starts off with you
know you have a ten-year-old and an 18
year old trying to have chemistry which
we discussed previously in a different
round now we're discussing now but I
think you and you have this love story
that literally this love story defines
the trajectory of whether Darth Vader is
good or bad and the three movies that we
already loved from the 70s and 80s we
saw that pay off and to see something's
pay off to see the result of something
and go back to the root cause and be
like oh really like that's your time
tell me like that's what caused this
like I love this character and I love
this world you've built and like this is
the crap that it came from like you
couldn't do better casting also hidden
Christian is just a terrible actor wait
did you say they couldn't do better
casting the Natalie Portman but Hayden
Christensen okay it was great
Natalie Portman I am team Natalie
Portman yeah
good person she carries it she cares to
my point ball you have you have one good
person in this movie who should be able
to carry it and instead she doesn't
carry it she literally like carries it
in every other movie she's ever been and
was so many romantic love stories with
so many different people kind of
actually some of what you're saying
about bond he carries it in all these
other movies
whereas in 50 sheets are great they had
one relationship they had one person
they had to pretend they were in love
with on screen and they couldn't it's
like right love with her when he looks
at her she's supposed to change
everything and make him not want to do
what he does and and everything and
you're looking and go it looks like you
just saw a girl pick her nose like why
are you looking at her and being like
I'm in love but she's also a terrible
movie that's what's really tough about
this is that it's a terrible movie so I
don't know if like any chemistry could
save it so I don't think maybe the
chemistry was not as much an issue with
Fifty Shades of Grey as it was just the
like writing and the overall movie
exactly when Phantom Menace is the order
you didn't pick Phantom Menace I'm sorry
say okay Caden and Natalie is that like
like I hate to say but the writing and
the prequels is atrocious
like ya screen test they might have
great screen tests where they were like
feeling it and then once they got their
lines are just like with terrible
writing good chemistry can can make you
forget that the job is to make bad
writing sound good that is literally
good job every chapter exactly like when
you have an actor that has proven how
good of an actor they are like Natalie
Portman and she can't do that with
somebody that is the fault of that
actors chemistry and so you know what
I'm not even saying it's the two of them
I'm saying it's him he has the worst
romantic and any person in any movie
said that it's one person on yours
both of my people sucked alright great I
find closing I'm you can add more if you
like but again why is your we I believe
all yours are the worst why is it worse
than the other two last thoughts going
to you make all right so basically bond
it's all about the Bond girl and bond at
the end
gonna make us think something and get us
make us think that this is it that this
is his lady and we got nothing here at
the end of the Bond girls I mean sorry
at the end of the Bond movie it was just
vapid it was awful this made a bad movie
even worse their chemistry was I mean
like I feel like these these answers are
a lot more obvious like this is think
about it like when you're a Bond girl
that's like high expectations right
there this relationship is something
that we you know we're supposed to leave
and we're supposed to be jealous of it
because bond is just like a you know
best guy just like top of the line and
we got nothing with this and well we got
was boobs it's all we got all right
you know what do you think final
thoughts when you have a story like
Fifty Shades where it's so heavily
reliant on the characters because the
story is so ridiculous and it's kind of
abusive and offensive to the BDSM
community what you would need to do is
you need to have people that you believe
are in love with each other you need to
have a man that you believe is not only
going to take you introduce you to new
things and then take care of you and a
woman who is weak and and wants to learn
and and wants to discover herself and
what we got were two shells of people we
got a a sad portrayal of people who
clearly have never been in love and
Dakota Johnson's parents are actors you
expect her to be better you expect her
to know what she's doing and Jamie
Dornan has done well in other things but
I guess when he's the lead all by
himself he can do it he can't show you a
relationship and and you can't fall in
love with these characters which somehow
even in that terribly written book you
feel something for them and you get in a
movie you go yeah I don't want to watch
this I'd rather watch real porn Manny I
think the biggest difference here is
that Star Wars is something that means
so much to so many people and anyone
who's ever been in love and been in a
relationship I think you care a lotta
more about a relationship when you
actually love the person that you're
with and for me Star Wars was a
franchise that I loved and that love let
me down and it ruined it ruined so many
things about that franchise and
for me it's those those high stakes of
that that it mattered so much for so
many people I mean stars isn't just a
franchise it is the franchise and I'm
sorry if you disagree with me but it is
literally like this is a relationship
and a romance that an entire world and
mythology and lore are based off of and
you couldn't sell it and that's a
problem Adam dan I'm going to get you
both thoughts on the couch
nothing to add I'm just kind of going
over it over in my head I'm a big bond
fan yep
and I never watched it for the
relationships being honest
so that really didn't ring true to me
that you'd be disappointed in the
relationship at the end because like
maybe it's just me so for me it was like
her life you did maybe this is the girl
for him that was a good I think she said
cuz you do won't even lose like that
most girls watch that and they want bond
they want to be with bonds it's a little
different I personally have never walked
out of a Bond movie go like oh I hope
he's found the love of his I I think
that Yale actually did the best for me
as far as describing both parties why
the movie didn't work why they didn't
work in particular both in real life and
on screen I thought that was the best
argument for me so that's coming you
agree mm yeah Mary and Meg both said
that half of theirs were great like
Natalie apartments so great and
everybody wants bond and then Yale just
that was a deathblow when she said it
takes two people hey Mary what did I
underline here - what - actors have the
worst chemistry on-screen chemistry and
I think yes yellow pointed that out and
that you both sort of admitted you had
someone in there that was a
once I heard that I was with them as
well that they're really both terrible
in Fifty Shades mega thank you will give
you proper plugs at the end let's wrap
the show though yeah you're staying
there okay we are moving to the speed
rounds oh no pressure guys here's how
the speed round works you've both done
it on TV fights right yeah so you know
how this works
twenty seconds then ten second rebuttals
not here right can we can have a
close-up sure yeah okay yeah way to get
to close ups right yeah all right here
we go
twenty seconds ten second row but O's if
you both say the same answer at the same
time it's whoever said it first here we
go
this is a creative answer just so you
know or ignore or a real answer but you
got to think a little harder what actor
would be the worst possible choice to
play Batman Jamie Dornan Jesse Eisenberg
oh alright Jesse Eisenberg and Jamie
Dornan Yael you went first so whenever
you're ready the time will start when
you started speaking Jamie Dornan
who is best known for Fifty Shades of
Grey and the sequel and he's also known
for the fallen I believe and he is not
very good at being a hero he's not very
good at being romantic and part of being
Batman is you gotta win hearts and save
people okay I feel like Jerry Jamie
Dornan brings a lot to the fall actually
he shows a little bit of personality
Jesse Eisenberg not only doesn't fit the
physicality of Batman because Batman is
known for me the physicality but Jesse
Eisenberg is known to being one of
Hollywood's most unlikable actors and
this presence is one of the most
unlikable presents on screen so I feel
like that it really knocks off for
Batman and the whole thing about being
Batman is you want to be like him Jesse
Eisenberg
adapts to his roles and that's something
that he can do he's willing to take
risks whereas Jamie Dornan is kinda the
same character all the time Bruce Wayne
is someone who is a competent
businessman Jamie Dornan has already
shown to do that in one of his movies I
feel like Jesse Eisenberg not only has
proven that he can't take on physicality
of certain roles but he's just a
presence that you do not like on screen
you get two extra seconds I disagree
that Jamie Dornan did it well okay even
the time there I'm coming to you first
some arguments based on the arguments
I'm gonna have to go with ace he gave me
a little bit more and he also said that
he Jamie Dornan has shown that he can do
the business thing before whether it was
right or wrong he has yes it's true dan
you know came out of the gate slow for
me but she actually won me over at the
end by saying well you know just the
Eisenberg actually takes just and takes
her risk whereas Jamie Dornan is kind of
OneNote and that she she she won me over
I was with ace until that I was that and
that's what I wrote to and I was my note
I'm in the fence but I I agree as
slightly over guess he played it but
then she didn't even counter he didn't
play it well so that helped out counter
that base so I got to give Yale the
first point game here we go
in honor of mother which a film I did
not like went several probably will so
go make your own judgment call who's the
best mom and movie history he said it
not me
pick a mom Charlotte haze in Lolita okay
the 97 version oh man I'm terrible at
these just verify that Danner try to
find out that's a that's correct name a
mother in a movie confirming the
character I guess a Martha Kent in the
new Man Steel movie which yeah okay
alright and you know you're up first
Charlotte Hayes was a mother who was
looking she was a single mom and she
chose to let a a man come and stay in
their home so that they could pay the
rent she took care of her daughter she
and she tried to be the best moms that
she could I feel like Diane Lane brought
was a lot of tenderness and a lot of
heart to the row of Martha Kent I feel
like the one scene that she has with
child Clark where she's hugging him
after he has that x-ray vision that
scene in itself sells the love that
Clark has for his mom and even when he
comes back home after Paw Kent has died
that whole chemistry is brought together
by what scene that that gives you
chemistry where is the whole first act
of lolita is the mom showing how much
she cares her a daughter yeah and how
much did she
I'm not saying one scene I'm saying that
once he brought a lot out of it I think
there's several scenes that show her
warmness and her tenderness and her
ability to connect to the actors and the
characters of Clark Kent and that's
eventually what obviously he fights for
is that all the time I'm all right guys
might be more about what wasn't said I I
think I'm still going with a scream
there
oh no that's why I said this is more
about what it wasn't said all right
which movie should Jim come in a name to
okay it's not broad which movie should
Jim Carrey reboot Ace Ventura or the
mask the days for true oh okay you both
different you know pick the mask and ace
picked ace yeah all right I heard mask
first the mask was such a beloved movie
and it was so fun and people still have
great memories of it and that's why it
should be remade whereas Ace Ventura you
know it was funny and they were two or
however many but the masks was a
standalone and it was so beloved and
there was a great history to the story
of the mask itself that like gave you
this great mythology which made it so
beloved - I feel like there's still
moments in Ace Ventura that we remember
and that my friends and I quote and that
we can have reenact like the moment
where he's going out fro it and
everyone's balancing around I feel like
that's hysterical in itself I feel like
the mask is just one item it's something
that you can put almost any actor in
whereas what Jim Carrey brought to Ace
Ventura is his own personality his own
comedic value his own comedic timing Bay
is completely original I disagree I
think the mask is such an amazing
character that pretty much only judge
Jim Carrey can do he did all these
physicalities and and beautiful voices
that only he can do and it's such a
quotable I feel like the mask is more
based on what that is it's the mask
whereas Ace Ventura is based on the
character itself we're only Jim Carrey
can embody that character and the
comedic timing for that character is
done through that that's the time that's
the time yeah I thought Jim Carrey it is
definitely it but it needs to be in both
of those roles he shows himself what did
you guys think in the couch I that was
really close
I think the thing that won me over was
y'all talking about how the mask might
have a bit of a deeper mythology to it
I kind of signed with her on that he's
kind of doubled up on both of his
speaking points I got the point same
point towards race there we go we're on
the same page yeah you got a second
points all right guys
best movie based on a TV cartoon series
Josie and the Pussycats I'm sorry on a
cartoon series TV cartoon series best
movie Batman Begins based on Batman the
Animated Series is that can I do that no
needs to be like a cartoon adaptation
I'm terrible at these
jj-just fainted in the booth five-four
I'm really bad news I'm sorry guys
- movie that was based on TV cartoon one
and a half scooby-doo Batman mask of the
phantasm okay gonna said that right you
can't say that now cuz you pick
scooby-doo Josie yell you're first and
then aces up what scooby-doo yeah
josie and the pussycats was a fun movie
that had a lot of big stars in the movie
Tara Reid rosario Dawson it was an
amazing film that you know showed
sisterhood and friends and there was
music and there was amazing product
placement that was part of the plot and
that was really fun and and it just was
this great movie that reminded you of
how fun that show was as a kid even
though was a different story
I felt like what's gonna do brought was
it brought that cartoon to life it was
the cartoon in an actual movie where
there was Freddie Prinze Turner playing
his character Sarah Michelle Gellar
or shaggy I feel like those are the
cartoons coming to life and as and it's
cheesy and is over-the-top that was
that's what you wanted in the cartoon
because the cartoon was cheesy and it
was over-the-top and that's what we got
in the movies because that's what it's
delivered scooby-doo was too on-the-nose
it was too easy and what Josie the
Pussycats did was take the characters
and bring them into our world and make
them more relevant and approachable and
give you this whole other story I feel
like scooby-doo is four kids in the
cartoon and they made a live-action
movie for kids it was funny for kids and
it did that in the recreation of
bringing it to life with the same
outfits the same clothes it was very
authentic that's all the time yes whoo
tough for me yeah any thoughts - no it's
pretty easy for me I thought then I
thought that ASA was just kind of giving
us Scooby Doo
mr. hood fun yeah sort of did that right
yeah I was I was a little bit more on
the fence and and was but you know
saying that it did something different
and they took something that we love but
also did something we did do do did wear
the same costumes that was a good point
I still gotta get point to yell welcome
to the roster but I want to thank
everybody here take a turn that mic when
I call your name but a second place ya
[Applause]
[Music]
know my youtube channel ID squad leader
ace where I talk about anime cuz I love
anime and also a new podcast coming out
on the sk+ channel which is to spin off
of the schmoes no it's called the
meaning of talking about film so yeah
check me out there Mike what would you
like to plug um you can just find me on
all social my handle is at am risque
amor I ask you is on the screen you can
do Matt knows most of the top tenth TV
show a top ten show with over TV oh yes
sorry that's right what else would you
like to plug their odd nothing just find
me the Twitter handle I can give them
all the information once they reach out
to me there thank you for having me
thank you for coming you were great Bret
register DC y'all access DC kids what
else you got you watch that I got a
podcast with Steve Zaragoza called the
first time show or it feels like the
first time at first time show on Twitter
and we're going through lost two
episodes of the time I never saw it so
my first time through we're on the
finale so I catch up quick from movies
with Meg meg McCarthy hey guys thanks so
much for having me this
Blastoise find me unsocial at movies
with Meg Jo right there cool thank you
Bravo dig child man hi sorry for
screaming and pointing at everyone you
find me at Mr Dave child or Dave child
calm I do a bunch of afterbuzz shows and
you say Mr not mister just find me there
I do a dance troupe - I am chubby bunny
I also have a weekly anime show also
called hyper otaku which is on hyper
RPGs twitch channel every Tuesday as a
car mad monster where can people find
you mad monster calm Instagram at mad
monster Graham Twitter mad monster Meg
[Applause]
great for me cuz you all came so ready
to fight and I want all of you to come
back if you're willing thank you for
doing it Dan Merle on the couch shift
weight from tonight I will be
Florida State my alma mater was nice
enough to invite me to come to a QA a
week from tonight I'll be at the Student
Life Center Florida State with Alicia
below will be doing a Q&A after Wonder
Woman so if you're in Tallahassee if
you're a floater state's free if you're
a student it's ten bucks if you just
want to come hang out but next Thursday
night at 7 o'clock the movies at 7 the q
and A's after next Thursday you'll be
there I'll be in Florida it's just a
bummer because next Thursday max landis
will be here except for that fight
Adam tear thank you for coming you were
great thank you for help then you
brought it what would you like to stab
to plug just to shout out to my buddy
John who's serving overseas in Japan
yeah
[Applause]
thank you John and thank you to you Adam
for coming and watching and being a fan
that's it that's all we do you can find
me at eighty Signori twitter instagram
and all the other things please be nice
to everybody and have a wonderful week
we'll see you next time bye bye this
episode is brought to you by t-mobile
want to hear how America's best
unlimited network is upping their game
now get Netflix included with your
family glad there's never been a better
time to switch
[Music]